it's easier to follow Trends to find  success as long as your metric of  success is clicks and Views and plays  and all those things which do have  Financial attachments to all of them  um than it is to just trying to pursue  what is creatively socially meaningful  and now that's the pursuit forget about  the means like the focus is in honor  means the focus isn't on making the best  music so you can become You Know Rich  and Famous the focus is just on how do I  become rich and famous and social media  has shown us that in a more Vivid way  than any other sort of artistic Endeavor  the path to success  as it's defined there money and fame has  never been more Vivid it does make me  want to go back and purely focus on the  create the creative and see that if I  can use my platform which is still big  um to find success that that will be  very reassuring